andrew lincoln the guy who uh plays uh
rick rick yeah like is he so into method
and being an actor that he yeah he he
had a fight with you and broke your nose
yeah since i last saw you right yeah the
mid-season finale this year yeah so uh
remember where i'm blowing up alexandria
and i say i'll be in the house making
spaghetti send rick to me yeah and he
comes in with a machine gun and i pull
the bat out it was that fist fight
and
i knew he was gonna punch me because he
gets so amped up and he does wow and he
drinks a ton of coffee and he just gets
excited and he loves it you know and
that adrenaline gets flowing like i i
mean i've seen it before but pull your
punch pull your butt don't you you guys
rehearse that stuff oh yeah rehearsals
are always fine second cameras are
rolling it goes up to it goes from like
50 which is fine for cameron yeah it
still works to 130 percent oh dear um
take me through that whole thing so like
you're on the set you're working this
thing out are you like oh [ __ ] you just
broke my nose yeah i mean it was i i
almost immediate i mean i immediately
what happened was uh
you know i i knew
we were too close i knew immediately
when the scene started and the camera
was rolling that we were too close to
each other but we're toe to toe and it's
like i punch he punches and neither of
us moves it's like we're both taking
punches you know what i mean yeah and on
like the second punch you just just
cracked me on the bridge of my nose
and i think i kind of dropped to a knee
but immediately you know when you get
hit in the nose your eyes water right
yeah and i stood up and i was like ah
dude yeah and he's like you know he was
there he's like more he was more upset
than i was um he's not an [ __ ] at all
he's a great dude he could control that
[ __ ] well you should pop him in the face
and humbly well you know at some point
you know what later on in the season i
kicked him in the nuts and it made me
feel oh you did yeah good for you yeah
yeah
let's see how the next one i'll say i'll
say this when he did punch me in the
face and we kept shooting i didn't stop
i mean i took a minute put some ice on
and we continued shooting um but the
next day he sent me a a a massage gift
certificate and a facial and
i don't do massages or facials but i i
got to tell you he is andy is one of the
sweetest people you've ever been in your
nose looks pretty nice i mean so what
did they do they went to a plastic
surgeon and no man we just popped it
back into place and i kept working i
didn't do anything yeah yeah it was just
i went and had an x-ray it was just to
look like a hairline fracture right up
here yeah
i don't know
real man yeah yeah it was cool i mean
literally 10 minutes later we were
shooting but i i don't want you i don't
want you to think he's an [ __ ]
because he is one of the nicest i'm
reading between the lines ah don't don't
do it
uh all right so now
now movies yeah man rampage yeah with
the rock
with the rock that's why dj and when you
were making the movie the rock knocked
you out too right like he punched you
out no he didn't punch me out he uh he
landed on top of me uh while doing a
stunt but he landed on top of me from
quite a distance what is
in the stunt we're on an airplane that's
going down and i'm unconscious like tied
up in a cargo net and
and he comes to kind of save my ass but
he flies from one plane
through gravity
on a wire comes zipping down he's
supposed to land next to me and he
landed right on top of me and and he
what does he weigh like 300 or so he's
got to be he's got to be i mean of solid
like i mean it's he's like a poor young
freezer falling on you you're like hey
i'm an actor i'm not looking to be
landed
on the nose the sound that came out of
my body
of all the oxygen and ribs cracking and
you need to go back on the good wife
and then i just hear him and i'm like in
my head i'm like oh [ __ ] i can't do this
again i hear him start giggling
i'm like dude
and he's like i guess we gotta do that
again i'm like ah